يلعب الناخبون المتارجحون او الحاسمون
غالبا دورا مهما في تحديد من سيفوز في تلك
الانتخابات الامريكيه من هم الناخبون
المتارجحون وكيف يصوتوا اولا يفضلون لقب
الوسطيين ولديهم بعض النفور من كلا
الحذبين السياسيين الرئيسيين هناك
افتراضين حول او افتراضيين حول
واشنطن بوست الاول هو انه في الاساس من
الوسطيين ولهم وجهه نظر متقاربه ويصوتون
لمرشحين اقرب الى الوسط والثاني هو ان
هؤلاء الناخبين بدلا من ارتباطهم بمواقف
اي من الحسبين يقومون بتحليل موضوعي لظروف
البلاد ثم الادلاء باصواتهم وفقا لذلك لا
سيما الانفصال عن الحزب الذي تم التصويت
له سابقا اذا كان الاقتصاد
الناخبون المترجحون غالبا لا يتمتعون
في ليبراليه او محافظه في جميع المجالات
ويفضلون ان يتم التعريف بهم على انهم
معتدلون ولديهم نفس المسافات من الحزبين
الديمقراطي والجمهور طبعا لكن في ذات
الوقت هناك فئه اخرى لديها مزيج من
المواقف الليبراليه والمواقف المحافظه
وعلى اساسه يقوم افراد هذه الفئه باختيار
مرشحهم المفضل البعض الاخر يحلل في مركز
معظم القضايا الرئيسيه لسياسه الداخليه
والخارجيه لنواب السابقين وعلى اساسه
التصوير وايضا هنا فئه وتعتبر صغيره من
الوسطيين او المتارجحين ليس لديهم مواقف
سياسيه وجل اعتمادها هؤلاء على الاقتصاد
والقضايا القانونيه والاجتماعيه والقوانين
الاجتماعيه الى حد ما قضايا المراه
الامريكيه وهناك نقطه اخيره على هؤلاء
المتارجحين فهم لا يحبون ان يروا نفس
الحزب في البيت الابيض لاكثر من فترتين
لذلك يسعى اولى الناخبون المتارجحون لمنع
اي من الحزبين من الفوز باكثر من ولايتين
ما قد يقلل من حظوط الديمقراطيين هذه
المره بهذه الانتخابات